i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't i've
tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there
you're done this is this is a no
this is a no i mean
we we all knew that uh senator manchin
couldn't be trusted um you know the the
excuses that he just made um i think are
complete
222 democrats in the house and 49
democrats in the senate have been
working in in good faith for six months
or longer trying to get this very
important piece of legislation done i
think a bit of arrogance on the part of
senator manchin who thinks that he
should have total say as to what gets
passed
well
i knew he was going to make news but i
didn't know senator manchin was going to
make that news i had about 10 more
questions about the specifics he built
back better and he said no it's a no
well the white house came out with this
really scathing
statement to jen saki writing senator
manchin promised to continue
conversations in the days ahead to work
with us to reach that common ground if
his comments on fox and written
statement indicate an end to that effort
they represent a sudden and inexplicable
reversal in his position and a breach of
his commitments to the president and the
sender's colleagues in the house and
senate justice senator manchin reversed
his position on build back better this
morning we will continue to press him to
see if he will reverse his position yet
again to honor his prior commitments and
be true to his word while the senator
reacted to that
it's staff it's staff driven i
understand staff it's not the president
it's the staff
and they drove some things and they put
some things out that were absolutely
and excuse the board they know what it
is and that's it i knew that we could
not change it was never going to change
it never could change with that many
people
so where are we let's bring in our panel
ben dominic publisher of the federalist
morgan ortegas former state department
spokesperson juan williams is a fox news
analyst ben what's your reaction and the
fallout from it
well first off i have to react to the
way that the white house staff
responded to this situation
you know look i think that anyone who
was paying attention to what senator
manchin really wanted his priorities and
everything that was going into this has
known for a long time the amount of
movement that would have to happen in
order for him to consider voting for
this bill he's been very clear about
that since the summer and even earlier
if you were paying attention about what
his criteria looked like and for the
staff of the white house to respond to
this situation by basically just uh
trying to bully him and calling him
essentially a liar
saying that this was you know a
situation where he you know uh was not
someone that they could respect going
forward because they couldn't trust his
views you know suggesting that he's
someone who
you know has been all over the map on
this one and from my perspective he's
been very consistent since the beginning
was just completely out of bounds and as
a former staff for myself i mean i i
just can't imagine that this was the
kind of thing uh that that they viewed
as as being a professional response to
the situation the senator himself i
think has been telegraphing this for a
long time and to suggest that he's the
only senator who has these views about
this measure is i think also inaccurate
i think there are a lot of other
senators who would have been with him on
this if it was not
something that would have been dangerous
for them politically and i think he was
actually speaking for a lot of people
when he said this thing is dead we
couldn't find a way to move it forward
and it's time to move on yeah
juan they still need his vote and if
chuck schumer the senate majority leader
is going to put put forward the build
back better bill as it's written
and make everybody vote on it ben may be
right there may be other senators who
have a problem with it senators who may
be vulnerable in elections to come but
steve clemons who's a friend of manches
wrote in an op-ed in the hill
this white house incivility is what lost
joe manchin in my view the control had
shifted from biden who had said don't
support this unless you can really get
behind it to a white house that wanted
to play the blame game this is not the
way biden usually operates he doesn't
blame either side of the negotiation he
usually works it through detail by
detail resolving the problem after
problem when tempers cool after the
holidays perhaps the white house will
see that with mansion temperament
matters juan
well i think democrats are in shock i
mean today it i mean you can't talk to
any democrat in on the hill today and
i'm talking about people who are you
know
liberal progressives uh you know from
elon omar that we just saw uh to abigail
spanberger and of course people at the
white house and they're they're all in
shock they had no idea that joe manson
was going to unilaterally call an end to
the negotiations um and part of this i
think for them is now the question is is
this a negotiating ploy brett or is this
really the end
uh and i think that's what you're
referring to in that hill piece is that
people saying well maybe it's the white
house attitude and if that attitude
shifts maybe then joe manchin will re uh
enter talks with joe biden as opposed to
anything that happened with the staff
but i think that what you've got to
focus on here and i think
you know i think from the
chuck schumer point of view from the
white house point of view just last week
joe manchin handed the white house a
draft of an outline if you will of what
was acceptable to him you know like a
point of negotiation he did the same
thing back in july
with the senate majority leader chuck
schumer so i think that there are lots
of people who do feel betrayed and feel
like wait we were negotiating we were
open to you the infrastructure bill was
passed separated from this social safety
net bill
and the elements of the bill are still
popular with the american people
the economists say it will not add to
inflation and yet you hear joe manchin
saying this is going to restructure
american society that doesn't sound
sincere right
well the economists there are different
economists who say would in
affect inflation and obviously inflation
is real and manchin is worried about
that juan and morgan
manchin has said time and time again
don't put programs in there that you
know are supposed to last 10 years and
only list them as one year in this bill
don't do the gimmick stuff and let's
make priorities is there a way possibly
forward yes but
maybe not the way they're treating him
here is mitch mcconnell on guy benson's
show radio show late this afternoon
i never get angry about losing a vote
because you know the most important vote
is always the next vote
so i was shocked at the vitriol
and basically it seemed to me they were
calling senator imagine a liar
think that was
not smart
this is a 50-50 senate
it's going to be 1550 for another year
and
believe me that's not that's not the way
i would have had a disappointing vote
like this
and morgan the underlying message there
is he's there with open arms if
manchester wants to come come to the
republican side
well it's not just that mansion broke
the news he broke the news on fox which
is an original sin for the progressives
and the party uh congratulations on that
bret by the way i think we were all
stopped uh in our tracks for sunday
brunch whenever you had that interview
um but listen let me i want to go back
to something that ben said that i think
is really important and that's the
staffing uh question and this is what
steve clemons wrote about in the hill
that you referenced earlier for our
viewers why does it matter what the
staff are doing and what they're
communicating
i think it's crucially important because
as staffing the secretary of state there
was not a statement that i put out that
he did not sign off on that he did not
agree to
so you have joe biden who is supposed to
be bringing everyone together whose
mansion's buddy and his friend and his
staff are beating up on him so there's
one or two things happening one
joe biden is approving all of this and
is playing buddy buddy to mansion in
private but you know is fully letting
his staff beat up on him or two his
staff is running amuck or issuing
statements even before the one that the
white house issued yesterday the one
that really set him off was a few weeks
ago excuse me a few days ago so
there's an issue here that either joe
biden is allowing his staff to do this
or his staff is doing things that he
doesn't know about issuing statements
that are really
upending the policy and political
debates in dc and i think that's
concerning
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else